in the previous video we learnt about
adding complex numbers to add two
complex numbers we simply add the real
parts separately and imaginary parts
separately to get a new complex number
we also note that multiplication of two
numbers say seven times three is just
adding seven thrice that is 7 plus 7
plus 7 which equals 21 is it that easy
in complex numbers how can two complex
numbers be multiplied let us multiply 7
plus 2i with 3 plus 4i we know that a
times B plus C will give us a times B
plus a times C it's the distribution
property so this can be written as 7
plus 2i times 3 plus 7 plus 2i times 4 I
now focus on the first part 7 plus 2i
times 3 it will be this number added
thrice 7 plus 2 I can be added thrice to
get 7 plus 7 plus 7 as real part and 2i
plus 2i plus 2i as the imaginary part
this is 21 and this is 6i
the result is 21 plus 6i we actually use
the distribution property here 7 times 3
plus 2i times 3 21 plus 6i the second
part is still pending how do we account
for multiplication of 7 plus 2i with 4i
this added x 4i does not make sense but
we can still use the distribution
property here multiplying 7 plus 2i with
4i we get 28 I plus 8 times I squared
which is nothing but 28 I + 8 x negative
1 this is nothing but 28 I plus negative
8 this expression equals the product of
these two complex numbers to get the
final expression let's add the real
parts and the imaginary parts separately
we get the real part as 21-8 an
imaginary part as 6i plus 28 I hence
seven plus 2i x 3 plus 4i gives us 13
plus 34 I let us pick up to more complex
numbers 3 plus 5i and negative 2 plus 4i
and work out the multiplication would
you like to try it first we can use the
distribution property here to write this
as 3 plus 5i times negative 2 Plus 3
plus 5i x 4i 3 times negative 2 is
negative 6 and 5 I times negative 2 is
negative 10 I we get negative 6 minus 10
I similarly 3 plus 5i x 4 I will give us
12 I plus 20 I squared as I squared is
negative 1 this can be written as 12 I
minus 20 and the last step is to add the
real parts and the imaginary part
separately we get negative 6 minus 20 or
negative 26 as a real part and negative
10 I plus 12i or 2i as imaginary part
hence their product is negative 26 plus
2i in both the cases we saw that a
product of two complex numbers gave us
another complex number is that always
true
keep this question in mind and try
solving the next example try multiplying
2 minus 7i with 2 plus 7i we will see
the solution in the next part of the
video
[Music]
you